here's a noise of a male or any Turk
you'll make when they are like ready to
bowl so when they get free those be
sitting there looking around and also no
girl that's no good that means that
turkeys gonna book I am Steven Rinella
I'm sitting here in the comfort of my
own home and this is the breakdown
[Music]
but for the wilderkin doing circle
hunting or stalking scene but it's
obvious that the kid learned what he
knows from watching hunting stalking
scenes in movies you know the
application of the face stuff movie
people TV people love junk on people's
faces if you look at hunters and use a
lot of face paint oftentimes are using
face paints they think face paint look
sweet I was using the RAM but when I was
a little kid and there's like a mud wall
and all of a sudden two eyes open on the
wall made of mud it's like oh my god
it's Rambo it's not a long muck his gun
handling is so bad that I can't even
address how bad is it's hard here to
untangle move eNOS and reality my theory
about this is the kid has been
instructed by their firearms expert to
not put your finger on the trigger
that's what things going on he's
stalking a bird but he's duties
herky-jerky bones and first off if
you're stalking something the ideas that
you're moving quietly and you're moving
calmly and you're not putting off extra
motion is gonna learn somethings
presents animals pick up movement
especially fast jerky movements if you
had strong desire is to actually get a
burden he winds up stalking a dog he
would hold that thing just still and
waits you actually see what you're gonna
shoot and then calmly raise it up not
this
[Music]
see when he does draw a bead I don't
hate it
his hands blocking so I can't tell if
he's using two eyes open or if he's just
squinting one eye which either case is
fine he's got a dominant right eye
he's shooting right-handed that hand his
forward hand which is very close to
trick guard it's not unacceptable it's
not great but there is a way to shoot
that way but again
someone's totally never put your finger
on the trigger so here he is drawing a
bead getting ready to shoot but still
his rear grip hand doesn't have good
control it looks funny and it looks
inept but I think part of a point here
is to demonstrate ineptitude when he
shoots his report doesn't match his
firearm
it appears he has a tube-fed 22 rifle so
were to shoot 22 off few hundred yards
away right now if I heard I'll be like
battle 222 it's like a very crack like
before and the other thing is there's
there's no kick the recoil is so light
it almost is recoilless I can't think
how many TV shows movies are banned
where someone gets blown back by a shot
you see it again and again yo classic
boom fall no I seen it happen one time
in my life it was to me I was 11 or 12
and I shot a turkey load out of a
12-gauge shotgun but I was unprepared
for it was poorly matched it's a very
lightweight shotgun pair of very heavy
shot shell and shot me back a little bit
but no it doesn't happen you get me food
the hell is that well I'd love to see
you doing you Peter
yeah that's like an old troll vegetarian
is a Native American word for a bad
hunter if you're fishing and you get
seaweed on your hook all the grass bass
there's a long history of sort of like
vegetation based bad hunting jokes when
it comes to wild edibles like
meat varieties in my circle of friends
we tend to focus on the really really
high quality ones that are in arguably
very good grams which is kind of a cross
you know wild onion and garlic tons of
wild berries are all great wide variety
of wild mushrooms are really phenomenal
next up we have the hunter oh the will
this is the Willem Dafoe one yeah this
booths ridiculous man would you want to
watch a real good hunt movie get dare
soon whose ala which means the hunter
but it's in Japanese and that is a
Kurosawa movie called the hunter mom
Siberian hunters so you're gonna watch a
movie called the hunter watch that one
not this one but in this one it's like
pharmaceutical or biochem company wants
to get their hands on a tasmanian tiger
everyone knows that of course has names
tigers went extinct decades ago but
there's the idea that it's a Lazarus
species meaning has name tigers went
extinct but then every year people see
him it's sort of the bigfoot of tasmania
but it's not a great analogy because
Bigfoot's never existed then people are
always thinking they're binding them but
in the case of tasmanian tiger it was
like a [ __ ] species it was a marsupial
predator lived in Tasmania it was
through habitat loss and over hunting
and predator control
wiped off the face of the earth and now
there's a lot of sort of excitement
about finding one so every year
something drunk out who driving home in
seasonal across the road and people bit
excited about over again so far no one's
been alike actually produced one the
great behalf of the movie is it it
suffers from the thing that movies often
suffer from which is called magical
backpack syndrome mean wonderful sets
off into the wild yonder to go hunting
trap and get himself a Tasmanian tiger
he's got a little rucksack but he
throughout the movie produces the most
stunning array of physical goods from a
little teeny backpack like a mini pack
that has a pickup truck worth of gear in
it
here is he's been out the woods for so
long he's frustrated and all of a sudden
wakes up and here's the damn thing
staring down at him he's also got some
hides hung out not sure what his
intentions are with the hide if you want
to preserve to hide in the field like
you're out for an extended period of
time where you need to do is you need to
get it flesh so he needs to get all the
fat muscle connective tissue off it and
get it down with what we would call it
clean leather and the best way to
preserve it is too salty
you can only salt the high once you have
it completely flash if you don't
completely flesh it and get it already
and then salt it it's a nightmare for
whoever then later has to try to salt it
it makes it nearly impossible so you
want to watch out for that he's in that
wet ass taint cave one thing that you
don't want anything to be wet you don't
want me to be wet you don't want Hyde's
to be wet what leads to rot
it means to stink don't get anything wet
ever how well can you see this my kid
was out with his little 410 shotgun and
got a weasel
so this weasel it's a long tail weasel
was fleshed and stretched inside out
certain animals are flesh and stretch
first side out with some inside out so
this is case can you can hear it that's
how dry this moisture would be the enemy
of this thing right now
go off to the Tanner in just this point
here's a hide that's been camp for
instance this is a muskrat side is what
we call to room skinned same as the
weasel
the only incisions were here and it's
pulled off like a sock this was to skin
retained so you can turned inside out
that's tan leather this is garment ready
you don't have a half head out this
angle it's funny the way our world is
full of leather shoes couches pole
street car interiors and no one finds it
offensive but when you tan it and don't
remove the hair and it becomes ferb man
you people get touching
[Music]
the guns a little out there you can tell
it's a little producer something about
that gonna look sweet probably not with
this guy would be totally with them
that's pretty sophisticated guns got
sophisticated optics and he's got a
quake sling like one of the best
cheapest slings out there the problem is
quake slings they use horrible hardware
so cut the hardware off and stitch on
drove tech hardware and then you got
like a really nice link I can't tell if
you did that but it's just funny because
there's a startup incongruity between
his rifle its optics in the sling but it
is a really good sling once you fit it
with good hardware
[Music]
it's kind of a touching scene because it
seems as though the Tasmanian Tiger kind
of resigns itself to being shot it's so
lonely that it wants to die exists the
last one left wonderful he's gonna shoot
it feels horrible but he's saving it a
fate worse than death would be that it
would be captured and experimented on
and just wanted to rest in peace I'm
very reluctant here to talk about shot
placement on an extinct species I would
never advocate any kind of shot
placement Tasmanian tiger but we're I in
a situation where God came down and said
you must shoot this Tasmanian tiger I
would tuck that shot right in behind the
front shoulder blade a little lower than
halfway up and down the body from this
here it looks like he's got really good
shot placement enhance off to the
special effects people because that
initial impact looks really legitimate
this movie is riddled with problems
earlier out but this scene for what it
is there's nothing really wrong with
this scene in terms of us getting
emotional shooting something I have seen
well in excess of a dozen people yet
emotionally and cry after killing their
first big-game animal the emotion
they're experiencing often has to do
with someone having a sort of reckoning
with all of the meat they've consumed
through their whole life and kind of
being divorced from this cycle of life
and death and they had the experience of
going out and killing an animal that
they'll eat and there's a deep gratitude
that extends from it maybe an
acknowledgment of a sacrifice and to
confront it and wrestle with it is
emotional and it's a little bit harder
and I'll point out that it hasn't
happened because I was introduced to
hunting and fishing the reality of death
at a really young age I never thought of
it as anything unusual but I'd like to
see people go through it because it
allows me to
in some ways live something vicariously
through that he's carrying the animal in
a curious way wasn't long ago was
hunting with my daughter we got a rabbit
she was carrying it that way it was kind
of funny to me that um that was sort of
her go to carry there's a certain bit
sized animal that can't be carried just
you know holding it in your hand like
imagine you're carrying a bucket right
you're carrying a bucket by the Bale a
lot of things you just carry that with
prints you grab a rabbit by the form you
carry it a lot you can grab a beaver by
the back foot and carried along with you
when people are dealing with a mid-sized
animal something up to a hundred pounds
could be comfortably carried over your
shoulders and that does happen it's kind
of this like domineering pose but it's
good because it distributes the weight a
nice way you'd be careful if it's
parasite load wouldn't want to put a
coyote for instance around you like this
really because they can have a lot of
mites that will in fleas that can get
off and getting your hair and they'll
bite you in two inches you could drag it
to but the problem dragging something
that's got a fur you want to retain is
you invariably like you drag and you rub
the hair off and create bald spots on it
so we'll often drag deer elk antelope
all kinds of stuff like that or you're
not worried about you rub some hair away
something where you want that hide you
don't want to drag it especially across
the kind of rough ground he's in here
you wouldn't carry it like this but
we're stepping into the directors mind
here it's meant to be that he's
remorseful
it's more of an affectionate sort of
carry alpha
[Music]
we're looking at Ice Age honors they're
hunting a relic species of Ice Age bison
unfortunately no one is around right now
who can tell us how Ice Age hunters did
their hunting but that doesn't mean
we're totally at a loss because we have
a lot of archaeological sites or we can
see where once played out butchering
sites remnants of tools weapons also we
have from later periods where
chroniclers or historians or travelers
and would watch how indigenous hunters
went about the chore of hunting bison
and what strategies they use and you can
wind up putting together like a pretty
decent picture of what went on all those
years ago they're all lined out in a big
long line if you're stalking and you
want to diminish your profile what you
generally want to do is line out so that
your prey it's not seeing things lined
out like this it's seeing things lined
out like this it looks smaller it's less
menacing than if we come at it like this
where you're creating a wall they're
sort of presenting this big line of
people maximizing its views so that it
can't be missed
yet they're crawling which I imagine the
filmmaker thinks looks cool they got mud
on their face which people love from
Bear Grylls not down but you can just
add dramatic appeal then we see kind of
like how ferocious they are our teams
like eating the ants off his arm sure
that's fine they're not gonna kill you
they taste bitter when you eat an ant a
lot of answer tastes like and took a
9-volt battery put the prongs against
your tongue but yeah I don't have
problem that dudes hungry
which party that is they go through all
this up the stock stock stock I need to
get up to the moment where you like
Karen keeping I can get me close with a
blown-out and some [ __ ] like oh like
what does it be right here ah yeah
which kind of undoes all the work you
just did toward stalking it
I also don't like their armaments their
weapons handheld spears like what
they're using we'll probably use more
for thrusting they probably weren't
curled or thrown but I don't see what
goes on here
they are driving a herd of bison off a
cliff and that did happen in prehistoric
times there are some bone beds in Europe
and there are bone beds in North America
where it appears as though literally
tens of thousands of bison were killed
at the edge of cliffs
oftentimes the cliffs weren't as high as
what we're seeing here and it would be
more that they would get maimed and
mangled when they fall off fairly low
cliffs and you'll sometimes see the bone
Bend spear points extend for a couple
miles out from the foot of the cliff
meaning all these crippled animals are
landing on each other and breaking bones
and getting hurt and wandering away and
then being kind of rounded up and
slaughtered by the hunters and it what
might have seemed like a pretty gruesome
display I would time was looking at
something this researcher did examining
a bison jump called bonfire shelter in
Texas and they wound up drawing up a
sort of digital display of what it would
look like from the Bison I view so it
imagines this animals moving 35 miles an
hour being scared by something that's
running across the landscape and when
you watch this video of what it looks
like to be moving at that speed at that
eye height toward a cliff by the time
the animal would realize that that cliff
was there it's too late man you got such
a mass of animals behind you pushing you
it's really quite surprising so now you
go the mountains in Wyoming you know the
mountains of Montana mountains of Idaho
and fine wool dried lines where people
build rock cairn to rock structures to
herd bison where you wanted to go when
you're driving them off the cliff here
they kind of take a little bit fanciful
approach and they're suggesting that
instead of building Corral's or some
kind of rock words to guide their
movements they throw a line of Spears up
to steer them it's goofy but it makes
for a good scene in fact kind of like it
oh no nails
let's come back finish mom oh you get
charged and wounded by something you're
hunting for is it far off it does happen
and there's certain species that are
really famous for it I one time wounded
a moose and got charged and hit by the
Moose's antlers he bowled me over when
it first happened I got up and I felt
where I got poked by its antler and my
hands came back all coated with blood
and I thought it was my blood I was
bleeding out I'm not scared but then I
realized it was blood from the mooses
own brisket that got all of my back
that's why I was getting blood on my
hands if you're watching a hunger
approaching animal you often approach it
from behind it when you might poke the
iBall if your arrow or poke the iBall
the muzzle you're done see if you get
your reaction from flinching if you can
touch something's eyeball and it doesn't
do any movement you can know it's dead
but yeah man if you're smart you don't
just go runnin up on stuff that you can
get messed up doing that next Django
Unchained that's a hell model I've been
shooting bottle since beginning quick
comment on snow shoes
so she's our funny thing because in real
life depending on the softness of the
snow snow shoes don't really become
advantageous until snow gets to a
certain death if you're what we call
postholing
meaning your foot is punching down
through the snow and it's knee-deep
saying every time you step your foot
crunches down in the wet snow snow shoes
are great they'll hold young Native
Americans the Great Lakes region where I
grew up we'd often read about how Native
Americans like to hunt moose they would
wait till the late winter snow was deep
and crusty and moose and game animals
will get hung up in the snow and have a
hard time but you could put snowshoes on
and go out in the early morning when the
snow was frozen and greased across that
snow and actually outpace moose and beer
and kill
[Music]
humans like to shoot bottles my
sister-in-law's ranch they have a whole
place set up where you go just to shoot
box to bottles is great but shooting
bottles is no way to test accuracy is no
way to test the firearms performance
because here's the problem
bottles don't do what this guy's
bothered us he shoots a bottle it just
punches a clean hole through the bottle
that's not happens when you shoot
bottles a nice break it's part of the
appeal but it's also part of the
downfall of bottle shooting is that it
doesn't tell you where exactly you hit
I like the still man thing has a nice
touch
shot plays it's so fanciful meaning if
you were to take that fire six-shot
revolver like he's got there put it in a
completely controlled environment well
there was no room for human error no
movement or flinch or whatever that fire
would not be capable of shooting a
pattern like that one shot out of a gun
is not indicative of anything you need
to shoot a three shot pattern or a five
shot pattern and you look at how all
those shots are gonna be distributed
they're not all gonna be in the same
place if you were to take the bat pistol
and put it out at 50 yards let's say you
put it out 25 yards no one is gonna be
able to take that pistol and fit in
anything much smaller than like a potted
plate it just isn't capable of it
there's always kind of stuff that
happens in movies ground accuracy it's
kind of ridiculous things are inherently
inaccurate so let's say our hero takes a
shot punches the center out of the glass
bottle I would then say I will bet you
that you cannot do that a second time
and I'll venture to guess that when you
just did that you were off and got lucky
you want something that just betrays
exact placement so shooting a piece of
cardboard shooting a piece of paper you
want something where you can have a fine
point of aim or you can aim at something
very small and see exactly where the
bullets hit but you know when I was a
little kid
our elana take a milk jug Philip pool
water set it up 75 yards away if you
could hit that jug you ready to the line
now if I'm shooting at 100 yards I want
to see a grouping of bullets within an
inch meaning you take three shots they
all fit inside an inch that's a tight
ass group and that's the kind of
accuracy you're looking for nowadays
next up the Hunger Games
[Music]
if you're in a situation where you're
not supposed to be hung the report of a
rifle can be a real problem makes a lot
of noise it's a dead giveaway
there's to be a thing like to be very
careful about shooting twice because
when you shoot once it's hard to place
it you know you might be like somewhere
out that way I heard a shot but once
you're paying attention you hear another
shot you're like oh no it was there
that's where that came from the second
one gives away but either way just like
a single shot alerts things to your
presence so if you're trying to be all
sneaky and be like a poacher or violator
and go where you're not supposed to go a
bow is a great option a lot of poachers
now use crossbows generally easier than
a traditional vertical bow and no sound
so you can be real quiet
[Music]
she's got a pretty sweet-looking
homemade bow when she goes to pull back
she'd oh she was obviously instructed
well and trained well has pretty good
archery form manufacturers of bows and
arrows and associated equipment they
were very enthusiastic about this movie
because they saw this whole new
clientele like the archery industry they
always catered to males of a certain age
when their twenties and third its
importance but also they saw this
enormous market from teenage women
wanting to go out and buy bowls and so
they'd received this movie quite
enthusiastically she gets lined up on
this dough but she doesn't have a good
shot she's only got a head neck shot it
can be done but it's not an ethical shot
a responsible hunter takes a shot that's
gonna be the quickest death most humane
death the most painless death you can
deliver to the animal and this is not a
great example an advantage of being in
my own home right now is I have some
visual aids I can show this is a deer my
old man shot accidentally in the head if
you look in here you can see what's cool
about it is the old broad head is still
stuck in there you shoot a recurve bow
with natural feather fletchings at a
white-tailed doe you shooting at the
deers ribs broadside shot but the deer
swung its head so fast when it heard the
string is like a full noise when you let
a bow go there's even a turn for 20
public it jumped the string meaning that
there's a time elapses between when the
air or leaves a bowl and let it arrives
at the target what typically happens
when something jumps strings as it hears
the noise and it loads up to bound and
so when you watch an animal slow-motion
jump the strength its crouching to load
up and then spring away and it drops
their back and arrows often fly it over
so when people talk off jump in the
string that usually shooting over its
back because its back dropped down this
deer was pretty far away mile man shot
it swung its head and one of catching
that broad head right dragging its
forehead and uh obviously stoned it you
know instantly dead here's no example
talk about like next shots I won't I was
hiking in Idaho I found this
skeleton and so I was looking at these
different processes that come off the
vertebra you could look here it's a
brand called mozzie there's a mozzie
broadhead in this vertebra this hit this
elk in the neck
missed the spinal cord by a quarter-inch
this didn't kill it it lodged into the
bone the bone healed around it and it
just rattles around in there this thing
died - no the winter coz that naturally
shed its antlers so he walked around on
the how many years with this mozzie
broad head embedded in its bone because
it didn't hit a lethal spot what's funny
this company their slogan is bad to the
bone but here we have it in a vertebra
[Music]
they're zeroing in on the gears nose
we'd say it's winning her it's getting
her way he's being implied with your
smells her bears have a different thing
to do in it when they smell they'll
sometimes stand up on their back feet
and put their nose up high and wave
their nose around on the wind and you'll
see sometimes deer that really smelling
something their tongue will actually get
active they'll work their tongue out and
we're tunnel work across their nose and
what we'll even say that that year is
tasting the wind you'll see them do that
when they're really intently trying to
smell or they might wave their nose but
here she's flaring your nostrils and
taking some breaths the hunter then
crumples up leaves to test the wind to
see what the winds do that's great like
that's a good way to test the win one of
the best and wind
testers in the world would be like the
down from a cat tail if you shred them
down from a cat tail and throw it up
it'll blow will use little containers
little bottles full of talc powder and
squirt that powder into the wind to
watch where it goes I used to just take
her breasts feather from the Grouch and
kind of fluff the breasts feather up and
hang it from a piece of dental floss and
when I was stalking elk or whatever I
would tie that dental floss and limb my
bow like that ruffled breast feather on
that dental floss would blow out and you
can see what the winds doing for those
leaves to behave that way would take a
hell of a win it's not that windy where
she is they got some kind of fan or
something blowing it's never that
exaggerated especially chunks of leaves
from the ground they're gonna be a
little bit wet if the wind is strong
enough to blow your indicator that
vigorously you don't need to wonder what
the hell the way the wind is going
because you can feel it blasting your
hair off in that direction too
[Music]
she's flushing the animal out well
oftentimes still rocks to see if
something's around
I'll do it hunting or not huh so guys
obviously curious about what might be in
some little hellhole or some little
brush pile down below me and I'll just
toss a rock down and see if I hear
something scurry or hear something stand
up a thing about that is in areas where
there is a lot of rock fall animals get
really used to rock fall so you might be
going along on some high mountain stuff
and kick a rock down and that rock board
room you like oh [ __ ] that's been scared
like I should have done that you guys
all day long rocks are falling animals
give an immune to that sound of rocks
falling but in a very targeted specific
way like this you could use a rock and
throw it or as she goes kind of
slingshots at aqua bolo string you can
do that to see if you get something to
move shirt the problem is once you get
the move it's moving so you need to do
it they're pretty informed the way
you're trying to get it to stand up or
move into an area where you might get
shot up
[Music]
so here again man she's got that tree
blocking the vitals she's very
conscientious and careful
the deers got to take another step and
then she'll have a good shot so like all
this kind of restraint and care
but then something person yells off in
the background and spooks it and then
she takes it Hail Mary at it anyway so
the fact that she would then throw a
Hail Mary after exercising such caution
and precision as a little out of
character for what I can tell about this
individual but you know you also gotten
tell a story right so it naturally
pushes them into stupid directions first
deer I've seen any year he picks up a
rock and oxen they must have such deep
familiarity of each other
it she knows the simple fact of him
picking up a rock means he knows that
there are some quail right there be the
way picks up a rock throws it flush the
birds gets a shot I have flushed play by
sucking a rock to get him to jump the
shot is really really something to shoot
a quail out of the air in a brushing
landscape like that would put you in the
absolute top echelon of archers ever if
you were able to do that consistently
daddy's home - no no no cupcake no I'm
sorry no the men do the hunting you
ladies cook what we kill excuse me the
Mel Gibson there is explaining that men
do the hunting and women cook and clean
what we kill anthropologists have looked
at that a lot it seems that Neanderthals
had less sexual dimorphism and that
perhaps men and women hunted equally the
suite of injuries that they'll see on
the and earth all remains being like
skull fractures various broken bones
they find that those injuries are in
line with the same injuries that we see
with bull ride
and withal had a confrontational style
of hunting me they were in clothes with
animals and getting injured by animals
and fighting with animals and they see
those Suites of injuries on both males
and females today in the United States
hunting participation is 90% male when
you go buy a hunting license you put
down your address or social security
number
like we know who you are right there's
no mystery I've ever does a hunting
demographics guy talking one time where
he explained that women that hunt tend
to be the oldest child or tend to not
have male siblings where the dad was
actually putting this position where
he's like I don't have a boy to bring so
I'll bring her it's just a shitty
reality about men women hunting
tendencies yeah that's the spirit
she's using a light gauge shotgun fitted
with a scope which you could do doesn't
really make a whole ton of sense but
that's what she's doing they're talking
very loudly which would spook turkeys
but then you have a lot of suburban
turkeys in this country that aren't
gonna be scared away about people
talking you could be in someone's yard
New Jersey to find turkeys there
nowadays ah there's more turkeys now
than there's ever been in the history of
our country Megan are you sure this is
what you want to do there's a lot going
on this season she demonstrates this
sort of what lost and no Gibson's China
leg reinforce the bloodlust will
Pharaohs come there are you sure that
you really wanna be this way they're
having kind of this national dialogue
about hunting here as this little girl
bears down on a turkey in herself
defying some kind of gender stereotypes
barky mark here he gets out a little
squadron that collar is the easiest way
to make a rudimentary turkey call which
is you can't mess it up really just go
like this and you get a turkey call the
harder it is to make a basic sound with
the call it just so happens that that
call is probably the most nuanced and
allows you the greatest vocabulary
serious turkey hunters tend to use three
types of calls there's a box call
some wooden box you got a paddle this is
the paddle and you chalk
that's chalk on there and it really is
you just can hold it
[Music]
that's a Yelp with a box call this one
is called a slate or hot and PEG pop
call slate call a glass traditionally
they're made with slate like here's one
that has a legit piece of slate you also
can make the same sounds with a piece of
glass and scratch up you can make a
variety of hand sounds I've killed a lot
of Teresa just noise nothing but that's
all it takes
then there's a final classification of a
call called the diaphragm call you'll
just hear in common in vernacular people
say a reed or sometimes people called a
mouth call the body is tape there's a
little horseshoe shaped piece of
aluminum crimping a piece of latex you
can buy condoms at the drugstore and
stretch that same condom latex and get
one of these the first thing you wanna
learn how to do is you're putting them
all to make a noise there's a noise and
then you can start forming turkey
vocalizations
here's noise the Turk you'll make when
they are like ready to bowl so when they
get freaked does be sitting there
looking around and also no go that's no
good that means that turkeys gonna book
then there's like a hands Yelp there's a
whole hundred things you can do with
this to make gobbles purse clocks key
keys
Hollywood has a reputation among hunters
is being adversarial the hunting hunters
are reckless buffoons and idiots the
worst of the work strike so they
perpetuate the stereotype and here you
know it only makes sense that the guy
who's local about let's kill the thing
and in the end there's a hunting
accident
he gets shot in his arm and wounded of
course my father got shot the foot and
hunting accident late forties early
fifties honey exploded like GI is coming
back from World War two really took
their hunting in record numbers an
editor of outdoor life I think it was a
comment you can't teach an entire
generation of men to camp out in the
woods and shoot guns and not expect them
to become hunters and that was true
according to go hunting safety did there
were a lot of hunting accidents those
before we had the hunter safety rules
and all these things and before best
practices were widely understood since
then yet the past who certain hurdles to
learn safety when I was a kid you had to
be a lot older to hunt than you do now
in most states like for instance where I
grew up you had to be 12 to hunt deer at
the boat you had to be 14 to hunt with a
gun for big-game the trend now has been
to lower those ages as long as you have
a parent with you I take my kids owning
my oldest is nine he has yet to hunt big
game because in the state where we live
he can't begin hunting with me till he's
10 some people might think 10 sounds a
little young to go hunt deer I don't
think so I will start my son out hunting
deer he's 10
it'll be with me within arm's reach and
then my dog will be next up just like
with my son I will have her hunt turkeys
the year she turns 10 so hunt deer deer
she turns 10 then when they turn 12 they
have to pass hunter safety and go do
coursework and go to a class and do
proficiency testing to be able to hunt
on their own
oh yeah she redeems herself in the end
gets her turkey collected herself after
crippling someone which is a little bit
startling who continue to hunt after
shooting a human being she's shooting
the oversized gun so it doesn't fit on
her shoulder right they should cut the
stock off for her so she can fit it
against her shoulder properly but she's
doing as best she can with what she's
got looks great
Wow two for two up next No Country for
Old Men the Coen brothers and also you
know it's based on a novel by Cormac
McCarthy do a great job always like
they're really careful about details and
they take the time to get the details
right so it makes sense that in the
hunting scene they're gonna do the same
everything about it looks great okay
here we're seeing Josh Brolin Sue Ellen
I think is his name boss it's a bad hit
on antelope starts blood trailing it in
archery hunting it's the norm the norm
is that you're gonna have two blood
trail something rifle hunting it happens
but it doesn't have an as often hunting
with a rifle for big game typically you
see the animal go down with archery
typically you do not to get the traffic
and there comes thing when you're
tracking the blood trail Peters out you
get a bad hit it's not mortally wounded
the rain comes and washes the blood away
all kinds of things can lead to a bad
blood trail the blood has a certain look
to it it's falling out a certain cadence
and a certain size of drop where it's
landing relative to the animals tracks
might suggest that it's just dripping
off the animal and not being spurted out
from the arterial wound or lung wound
you can tell by the consistency of the
blood if it has a lot of oxygen that's
coming from the lungs if it's got a
green this to it if it's greasy if it's
got a little bits of muscle there all
these things tell your stuff and you
might be in a situation you're like I
don't mean to be debbie downer
we're not gonna find it but a good
hunter keeps looking and looks and looks
and looks and looks and doesn't give up
on it until you've exhausted everything
you can possibly try but it does happen
you get to a point where and can't
follow anymore you just run out of blood
and then you cut circles to do
everything logical go to where you think
it would have went maybe you know where
it would cross the river and check to
see if across the river there and do all
that stuff but yeah at a pole
you gotta give up I think a lot of
people give up way too easy and leave
stuff in the woods that didn't need to
be left in the woods it should go on you
go back the next day and try again it
had a point you run up or enough time
has gone by that if it is dead it's
rotten so if it's like a day like this
the kind of heat he's in if he was
tracking his antelope and you didn't
find it today but things when you're out
anyway it's too hot looking bloated and
stinky full of flies by the time you
find it so you got to find it quick he's
still kind of on the trail why is it
looking down seeing all these shot up
trucks and goes down here to have a look
you just have to watch your back track
stop the shady characters you know
schooled in warfare not better and he's
tracking the man and he has some
interesting observations he's wondering
if he's gonna stop to watch his back
track to see if someone's coming behind
him but he also knows his based on the
conditions out the desert he says he's
gonna stop and shade here we get up to
the end and he's looking ahead and he
finds a couple shade trees and he's very
carefully studying that area under there
we hung coos deer in desert environments
like this in the middle of day and a hot
day you would look for those same shade
patches under trees like a more open
brown there is the more enticing one
little shade tree is and you'll stop way
back and watch binoculars to see if
there are deer holed up in that shade
movies that do that anything has to be
like overblown and dramatic when in fact
things happen very slowly and quietly
it's quite such a better scene here it's
a tense scene but he's doing it
methodically slowly quietly with
precision it winds up being such a
better movie is such a more impactful
scene when you see it done the way it
would be done if you watch this movie
get to the end smooth is a great scene
where Tommy Lee Jones to talk about
having a dream in which were on
horseback and his father rides out ahead
of them
when I rode past I seen he was caring
for
in Hoorn white people used to do I have
to see the horn from the light inside
I'm about to color the moon his father
was carrying a corn of fire
now how many millions of people saw this
movie and read that book and didn't know
what the hell he was talking about
we saw Bob is in the old days people
take a buffalo horn or a cow horn wake
up in the morning and take embers from
your fire and fill the hollow horn with
embers then they would plug the end of
the horn and poke a little pin hole in
it so that a small amount of oxygen
could get in there and keep those embers
alive you could travel all day and then
dump the embers out and blow on them and
Kindle a fire so in the end everybody
sees the scene and the guy goes and he
was carrying with him a horn of fire no
explanation what the hell he's talking
about but people in the know would know
what he meant was he was going ahead and
he was gonna be able to Kindle a fire at
night because he was carrying an old
Buffalo horn full of embers that was a
remote edition of the breakdown T cube
I'm Stephen Rennell and thank you garage
[Music]